the movie starts in a high school in
korea where the english class is being
conducted although the teacher mr kim is
very strict and wants everyone to speak
only in english no one listens to him
enraged by the student's reckless
behavior mr kim picks on the dullest
student in the class jung-ho and asks
him to recite some sentences in english
however jung-ho can't speak a word apart
from hello and thank you this makes him
the laughing stock of the class and
everyone mocks him for being dumb it
turns out that this is a regular
scenario and all the students are fond
of bullying jung-ho they call him
heavy-headed as nothing can enter his
brain not even education while jungho is
hated and despised by everyone he has a
best friend named era who usually looks
out for him she always tries to help him
in his studies but jungho is so dumb
that he can't even perform basic
mathematics shortly after the karate
champion of the school kevin enters the
class he is 30 minutes late but no one
speaks a word everyone appears to be
scared of him even the teacher mr kim
and with a name like kevin who wouldn't
be terrified before settling into his
seat kevin smacks a few bullies in the
head but they can do nothing but take it
like men during recess jungho is on the
rooftop with a couple of bullies who
demand that he provide them with his
pocket money unfortunately when jungho
mentions that he forgot to bring cash
they beat him up mercilessly and
threaten him to bring double the amount
the next day after they leave a
distraught jung-ho climbs up on the
ledge of the building and prepares to
commit the unthinkable he apologizes to
his parents one last time and takes a
leap fortunately his landing is
cushioned by a bunch of electric
appliances but he gets zapped in the
process as he writhes in pain because of
the electricity surging through his
brain he narrates that he survived due
to the heavy head that his friends
always mock him for after school as
jungho is heading home with era he asks
her if he has any good qualities aaron
jokingly says that he has a heavy head
which saved him from an untimely death
as expected this doesn't sit well with
jung ho and he once again asks her if he
is good at anything this time era
becomes serious and responds that he is
one of the kindest sweetest and most
caring people that she has ever met she
also calls him her bff realizing that he
is in the friend zone jungho returns to
the ledge just kidding as the two
continue their conversation they
suddenly notice that a man has fainted
on the ground wasting no time jungho
rushes over to the man and performs a
mouth-to-mouth resuscitation to revive
him surprisingly as soon as he does so
his eyes turn blue and a computer screen
is displayed inside his brain in the
screen he has the option to download the
person's memories and save them in his
brain although jungho is still unaware
of what's going on he subconsciously
chooses an option which says english
language the next day at school mr kim
once again picks on the weakest student
in class jung-ho and makes him stand to
recite his day in english all the
students are eager to hear his answer as
they can't get enough of bullying him
however to everyone's surprise jungho
speaks fluent english as if he's a
native he himself is equally confused as
he doesn't know where or how he learned
english he's probably been watching
mystery recapped as he goes to bed later
while jungho is recalling his previous
day he suddenly remembers the incident
where a computer screen popped up in his
brain and allowed him to extract
memories from the unconscious man with
this he deduces that if he kisses
someone he can transfer their memories
and skills into his brain like some sort
of perverted neo just then the bullies
approach him and order him to come to
the rooftop they also threaten him to
bring the money or else there will be
dire consequences after they leave
jung-ho becomes scared because he once
again doesn't have any cash on him he
heads to the bathroom and tries to think
of a way to escape but because of his
useless brain gets no ideas meanwhile
the karate champion enters the bathroom
and goes inside one of the stalls seeing
him an idea finally strikes jung-ho's
mind he heads over to the stall kicks it
open and kisses the karate champion
passionately once again his eyes turn
blue and inside his brain he gets the
option to download a skill he chooses
the fighting option and saves it in his
brain but sadly before he can leave the
saw the enraged karate champion knocks
him over with a brutal shot later a
nervous jung-ho reaches the rooftop and
confronts his bullies as usual they try
to intimidate him with their puny karate
moves but this time jungho doesn't back
down instead he demonstrates his own
moves inherited from the karate champion
and dishes out a brutal punishment on
the bullies he beats them left right and
center and knocks them to the ground
effortlessly after teaching them a
lesson jungho leaves for class but not
before telling the bullies to return all
his money the next day in the following
scene jungho catches up with his best
friend era and the two spend some
quality time together they go through
several of their pictures and reminisce
about their past just then era mentions
that she has been accepted into a top
college this makes jung-ho sad as not
only is he going to be separated from
his best friend but he will also be
forced to study at an average college
however when jungho realizes that he
possesses a special power his moods
swiftly changes he could make out with
era and tell her it's just for her
skills but he immediately heads to the
library where all the schooltoppers are
studying and kisses them one by one in
this way he downloads the intelligence
of each of the toppers and becomes an
alpha genius student he also probably
gets himself put on some watch lists as
time passes by jung ho starts getting
near perfect marks on his tests and
becomes the envy of everyone he even
excels in all kinds of sports making him
the most popular kid in school although
he has many admirers he also has made a
lot of enemies most of them are the ones
who he kissed and stole the skills from
cut to a few years later jungho has now
become a top businessman in the city he
has reached this level by using his
ability to the fullest whenever he sees
an interesting person he kisses them and
downloads their memory one day he heads
to the parking lot and secretly
punctures an expensive car's tire after
a while the owner of the car a wealthy
businesswoman named hira arrives and
gets upset as she is already late for a
meeting taking this as the perfect
opportunity jungho approaches her and
charms her by fixing her car he then
takes her out on a date and he gets her
massively drunk here we get to know that
hira is one of jung ho's top rivals so
he wants to extract her business
strategy after a while when the two get
ready to depart jungho suddenly kisses
her he taps into her memories and tries
to download some confidential intel but
surprisingly the storage inside his
brain becomes full the screen constantly
shows an alert which warns jung-ho to
clear some memories before proceeding to
download new ones without thinking twice
he opens a random folder and deletes it
the folder turns out to be the
accumulation of all the memories he has
experienced with his now girlfriend era
meanwhile as jungho and hira are still
kissing era arrives and catches them
red-handed expectedly she becomes
distraught at the sight of him cheating
on her as she runs away crying jungho
follows her and tries to make her
understand that he was simply trying to
improve his business but she does not
listen shortly after he finally catches
up on her and rudely tells her to stop
crying since his memories with era have
been deleted he has no feelings for her
anymore now he has become a cold-hearted
and egotistical person he threatens hera
to stop crying or else he will leave her
forever hearing this from the love of
her life era gets even more devastated
so she decides to break up with him as
she walks away an enraged jung-ho shouts
that his life will be better off without
her as he is rich handsome and
intelligent he's also a [__] following
the incident the two stop talking and
become distant from one another while
aerys still misses her ex-boyfriend
jungho has become even more
self-centered and could care less about
anyone one day while he is practicing
golf inside his office era suddenly
arrives at his doorstep with her luggage
and reveals that she is traveling abroad
to pursue her higher education she had
expected him to apologize to her and
show the affection she always desired
from him but to her dismay jungho is
still cold and impudent he simply tells
her to have a safe journey without even
looking into her eyes having had enough
of his mean behavior era devises a plan
she knows everything about jungho's
special ability so she decides to use it
in her favor at first she approaches him
from behind and embraces him when jungho
turns around in disbelief she grabs his
face and kisses him passionately
although jungho doesn't want to select
any memories from his ex-girlfriend his
brain subconsciously downloads one which
contains all the moments the duo
experienced in their lifetime after era
leaves jungho starts having flashbacks
of the memories he starts seeing the
happy moments he had with era during
their high school days and also the day
they abruptly broke up because of this
he realizes his mistake and acknowledges
that she is the most important person in
his life in the next scene jungho leaves
his office and rushes to stop era from
reaching the airport after a bit of
running he finds her crossing the street
and shouts his desire to have her back
azera listens in awe jungho apologizes
for being rude and insensitive and also
mentions that he will treat her like a
princess from this day forward saying
this much he tries to cross the street
and get to her without looking at the
traffic and ends up getting hit by a car
the collision knocks him to the ground
and he hits his head hard fortunately
his heavy head once again saves him and
jung ho gets up from the road he then
approaches era and embraces her tightly
vowing to never hurt her again just then
the computer inside his brain starts
malfunctioning he tries to shake it off
but soon the screen goes black and he
drops unconscious a devastated era tries
her best to wake him up but to no avail
in the final scene arrow leads a now
wheelchair-ridden jungho to their school
and shows him around it turns out that
after the computer inside his brain
stopped working he lost all his memories
and now he remembers nothing era takes
him to the basketball court and mentions
that it is the place where they first
met it was a rainy day and she was
completely soaked in rain but out of
nowhere jungho approached her and
offered his umbrella he didn't care
about getting wet himself because
helping others always made him smile his
selflessness was the best trait about
him and though he was always bullied his
smile always remained intact as jungho
hears the story he softly smiles as if
he remembers the memories but we know
that he doesn't because he's a vegetable
now the movie ends as era tells jung-ho
memories are not what you steal from
others but what you experience in your
own lifetime subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching